so let's say we have a cup of water let
me draw the cup
so
it's one side of the cup
that's the bottom of the cup
it's the other side of the cup
and it's water well let me say it's some
liquid it doesn't have to be water
some arbitrary liquid it could be water
so that's the surface of it
so we've already learned that the
pressure at any point within this liquid
is it's it's dependent on how deep we go
into the liquid and one point i want to
make before we we move on and i touched
on this a little bit before
is that the pressure
at some point
it isn't just acting downwards or it
isn't just acting in one direction it's
acting in all directions on that point
so although how far we go down
determines how much pressure there is
the pressure is actually acting in all
directions including up and the reason
why that makes sense is
because
i'm assuming that this is this is a
static system or or that
the fluids in this liquid are are
stationary or even we could imagine an
object down here and it's stationary and
the fact that it's stationary tells us
that the pressure in every direction
must be equal especially let's think
about a molecule of water a molecule of
water let's say it's roughly a sphere
if if i have a molecule of water let me
do it in this corner because i'm going
to need the space later
if the pressure were different in one
direction or let's say the pre if the
pressure down were greater than the
pressure up then the object would start
accelerating downwards right because its
surface area pointing upwards is the
same as the surface area pointing
downwards
so the force upwards would be more and
it would start accelerating downwards so
even though
the pressure is a function of how far
down we go at that point the pressure is
acting in every direction
so let's remember that and now let's
let's keep that in mind to to learn a
little bit about archimedes principle so
let's say i submerge a cube
into
this liquid
and let's say this cube
this cube and let me draw the cube
up here so you
let's say this cube has dimensions d so
every side is d d
d
d it's dimension d so what i want to do
is i want to figure out if there's any
force
or what is the net force acting on this
cube due to the water
well let's think about what the pressure
on this cube is at different points
well at the depths along the side of the
cube we know that the pressures are
equal right because we know at this step
say right here the pressure is going to
be the same as at that depth and they're
going to offset each other so these are
going to be the same
but one thing we do know just based on
the fact that pressure is a function of
depth is that at this point
the pressure is going to be
higher i don't know how much higher than
at this point
right because this point is deeper into
the water so let's call this
p1
that's the pressure on
let's call that pressure on top pt
and let's call this point down here
let's call that pd
p no pressure on the bottom pb
right
and what's going to be the net force on
on this object on this cube
well it's going to be
the net force
the net force let's call it f sub n is
going to be equal to
the force
acting
upwards on this object and what's the
force acting upwards on the object it's
going to be this pressure at the bottom
of the object
pressure the bottom of the object times
the surface area at the bottom of the
object well what's the surface area of
the bottom of the object
well that's just d squared right any any
surface of a cube is d squared so the
bottom is going to be
d squared
and then
minus
and i i'm doing this because i actually
know we know that the pressure down here
is higher than the pressure here so this
is going to be the larger quantity and
that the net force is actually going to
be upwards so that's why i can you know
do the minus confidently up here
minus the pressure at the top so what's
the force at the top
the force at the top is going to be the
pressure on the top
times the surface area of the top of the
cube right
times d squared
and we can even separate out the d
squared already at that point so the net
force
is equal to
the pressure of the bottom minus the
pressure of the top or the difference in
pressure
times the surface area
of either the top or the bottom or
really any of the sides of the cube
now let's see if we can figure what
these are let's say the cube is
submerged
h units or h meters into the water
h
so what's the pressure at the top
so the pressure at the top
is going to be equal to the density of
the liquid which i keep saying water but
it could be any liquid the density of
the liquid
times how far down we are so we're h
units down maybe h meters
times gravity and what's the pressure at
the bottom
well the pressure at the bottom
similarly will be the density of the
liquid
times the depth so what's the depth it
would be this h and then we're another d
down right
so
h plus d that's our total depth
times gravity
all right so let's just substitute both
of those back into our net force
let me switch colors to keep from
getting monotonous
so i get the net force
is equal to
the pressure at the bottom which is this
and let's just let's just multiply it
out so we get
p times h times g
p
h
g
plus
d times p times g
d
p
g i just distributed this out multiplied
this out that's the pressure at the
bottom
and then minus the pressure at the top
minus
p
h g
and then we learned it's all of that
times d squared
right
so immediately we see something cancels
out ph g p h g
subtract cancels out so we're just left
with what's the net force the net force
is equal to
d p
g
times d squared
or that equals
d
cubed
times the density of the of the liquid
times gravity
well let me ask you a question what is d
cubed
d cubed is the volume of this cube right
and what else is it
well it's also the volume of the water
displaced right if i stick this cube
into the water and the cube isn't
shrinking or anything
that and let me i mean you could even
imagine it being empty it doesn't have
to be empty but that that amount of
water has to be moved out of the way in
order for that cube to go in right
so this is the volume of the water
displaced
volume it's also the volume of the cube
volume of water
displaced
this is what this is the density i keep
saying water let's just say it's water
but it could be any liquid this is the
density of the liquid this is the
gravity
so what is this volume
times density is the mass of the liquid
displaced right so the net force
is also equal to the mass
of liquid
display so let's just say mass
times gravity
or we could say that the net force
acting on this object is what's the mass
of the liquid displaced times gravity
well that's just the weight of
weight
of liquid
displaced
so that's a pretty interesting thing so
if i submerge anything
i
the the net force acting upwards on it
or the amount that i'm lighter by is
equal to the weight of the water being
displaced and that's actually called
archimedes principle and that net upward
force due to the fact that there's more
pressure on the bottom than there is on
the top
that's called the buoyant force and
that's what makes things float
so i'll leave you there with with right
now just just to ponder that and we'll
use this concept in the next couple of
videos to actually solve some problems
i'll see you soon